[Music]
[Music]
ten
[Music]
elements of times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
with
clogged
that donald trump was flushing down the
toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumps
for elements of bathrooms
[Music]
big massive dumps
duties
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at that look at that
look at that look
who thinks he's smarter than you why
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers
this is
[Music]
tyranny
look at that
corporate tank over censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now very very upset with me look at
that that is a freaking predator right
there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
old water because pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
that is telling my children
your destiny
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
[Music]
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave beckman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three boxes
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
down
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
[Music]
don't raise the price
[Music]
well what an incredible day for such an
introduction we are here
apparently on the precipice of what
appears to potentially be looking like
the start of the beginning of the early
stages of the very first part of
is that enough disclaimers
the russian invasion of ukraine
um
earlier today
vladimir putin recognized two
breakaway regions in eastern ukraine
at the time it was said
this is a provocation
this is the creation of a pretext on
which to send in troops
and unfortunately
many on the right
and some on the left
said
no
no
and now
well listen if you recognize those
breakaway regions
you've got to keep the peace
putin orders
peacekeepers
into eastern ukraine well
i mean you can't let things get crazy
there right
you've got people there you've
recognized the regions
this was exactly
exactly
what was predicted hours ago
and fortunately
even some of the people on the left
who refused to see it are starting to
come around to it now i don't want
war
in fact i'm very worried about my stunks
if you look at the pre-market u.s
futures
are in a toilet that even 10 to 15
flushes won't help you with
elements of bathrooms right
dow futures already down one percent
s p down
two percent
nasdaq
or nasdag as trump used to say down
three percent i don't want this
i don't want any of this i don't want my
energy to go up
i don't want my supply chain to be
slowed down so i this this is all
horrible but this is the way that it's
going
russian president vladimir putin
formally recognized the independence of
two moscow-backed breakaway regions in
eastern ukraine
this was seen as a provocation and
possibly part of a pretext to invade the
us and eu swiftly announced sanctions
now the areas in question are right here
i i might i'm not i don't you know i
don't know
what my uh pronunciation is like here
but the donetsk region and the luhansk
region as you can see ukraine is bigly
very big
russia even bigger and we're talking
about these areas right here okay now
the what putin has done
is he is recognizing
the separatists there
um and this is
you know
this is not a perfect analogy it's not a
perfect analogy
but this would sort of be like i mean i
should i even do an analogy because
there's because there is no perfect
analogy
and this might trigger a lot of people
and create unrest among my own audience
i don't know if i want to do that
i mean listen it's vaguely vaguely in
some extremely vague sense
like if um
it's like if mexico mexico going exactly
it's like if maxellco said hey listen
there are separatists
in
texas and arizona
and we recognize them as legitimate
elements
of the
mexican state mexico
and
then oh hold on a second oh my god
i we've already got to ban people dear
god get the hell off my stream you
people you're all getting banned
you're all getting
oh yeah let's do well let's not even do
mexico imagine
that the quebec separatists
um
wanted to be
part of the u.s not their own country
but they wanted to be part of the u.s
and so the u.s goes hey listen we
recognize those separatists as a sort of
like state in exile
and so now i mean since since we
recognize them we're going to send
peacekeeping troops to quebec right i
mean get the hell out of here
get the hell out of here guys mexico
mexico or quebec whatever
um
and again it's it's not a perfect
analogy
um i'm being told
that the bbc
is now indicating yep the bbc is now
here we go guys
here we go we don't even have to look at
only the jerusalem post here we have bbc
putin orders troops into eastern ukraine
it appears to be starting
several airlines are suspending flights
to ukraine over invasion fears
uh it appears to be getting going it
appears to be getting going and uh not
what we want to see
even in the slightest
even in the slightest
um i have so many things to look at here
and people endless people texting me
updates about what's going on
uh okay bbc friend letting me know about
that
um
now i do think that it's important here
to mention that when people say insane
things about this situation they should
be correctly
criticized but when they admit their
mistakes then we should say hey that's a
great thing that you admitted your
mistake let me give you an example
here is a recent tweet
from hassan
who says earlier
it's monday
and it seems like russia still hasn't
invaded ukraine as all the high-level
intelligence suggested
maybe this week hope not anyway lots to
talk about and then
here is hassan just 56 sorry 54 minutes
ago how dare i 54 minutes ago saying i
was wrong
i was wrong
the russian recognition of eastern
ukrainian territories as independent and
the subsequent russian troop activity
into said regions for quote peacekeeping
is one hundred percent
an aggressive escalation that absolutely
moves away from diplomatic talks that's
hassan and as you can see i popped in
and said yes
correct
correct and a lot of people respectfully
addressing me as sir
that's david sir glad it's all being
kept very very professional
professional there
uh okay here's a drawing of hassan very
good now that's an example of someone
who corrected their mistake
okay and we will ban men here's an
example of a different type of grifter
this is glenn greenwald and look at look
at him go
this is the moment when u.s journalists
really get to shine they put on their
toughest war rhetoric tell americans
about the virtues of sacrifice and
summon the courage to all unite and
denounce putin and assure everyone all
the blame
lies with him and him alone it's
inspiring so this is glenn greenwald's
thing of how
uh everybody wants war
now if any of you have been watching
this channel for like the last three
weeks the number one thing has been
no i don't want war
yes putin is the aggressor
yes putin is doing exactly what we
expected he's first saying hey we
recognize some of those breakaway
regions with separatists oh we got to
keep them safe let's send in
peacekeeping troops it's happening right
now before our very eyes
uh the u.n is live right now let's
listen and see what's happening these
special procedures and the upr can
powerfully contribute to concrete
solutions on prevention protection and
sustaining peace and development thank
you for your attention
i thank the ambassador of djibouti for
his statement
and i have the pleasure
of giving the floor to the
representative of fiji mr ambassador you
have the floor this may or may not be
about what's going on in ukraine right
now
thank you
vice
vice president my delegation aligns its
statement to the one delivered by chair
of group of 77 plus china and that
delivered by singapore on behalf of a
group of countries okay they may not be
doing uh ukraine russia stuff right now
we're going to monitor that
extremely strongly and very very closely
okay let's continue i do want to make
sure i don't forget anybody i want to
say thanks to neptune that crazy guy jen
here and a user who goes by the name
thick nips
who have signed up all via twitch and
twitch prime including some gifts
putting us at five i do want to let you
know we have a new exclusive coupon code
today it's called please don't war and i
know that grammatically it doesn't make
a lot of sense but i think that makes it
interesting and it's please don't war
all one word all lower case i think i
have it here somewhere let's see if i
can test it
this is such an explosive coupon code it
could actually um
completely defuse what's happening in
russia ukraine please
don't war
okay
and then an extremely
powerful discount as you can see there
okay you can still use the code obama if
you want obama but the new code please
don't war
will do things
a lot of people didn't even think
possible okay now i don't know how many
of you speak russian i don't i am told
that in this video
there is a german operative saying at 4
00 a.m tonight russia time which is two
hours and 12 minutes from now east well
it's two hours and 12 minutes from now
no matter where you are okay
there will be
um
russia becoming great
which some believe is basically
indicating this was from december that
this has been been planned for a while
let's listen if somebody can translate
please
but it is
okay i don't know what on earth he's
saying
but um
i am told i am told
that uh oh wait a second
the february 22nd thing is a world war
ii reference okay
but four a.m on february 22nd
levy rosman could translate i think we
do need levy all right well listen
uh some people some people pointing to
that so we're going to look at that as
well here's the region that we are
focusing in on
um and we are monitoring a number of
different feeds
uh this is
live now from fox putin declares
independence for parts of ukraine nice
of him to do it right to give
independence to parts of a different
country
um
we are monitoring a feed from
kiev ukraine
uh and things look calm there
we are monitoring another feed from
maidan square in kiev
ukraine and this is uh
this sims seems to be uh equipment of
some kind i actually don't know what
this is
looks like people doing tool work
of different kinds
but all things that we are watching
extremely closely uh we have a bunch of
different super chats coming in fat
produce says as much as i hate to say it
it seems more and more that war with
russia is the only way to stop putin
i don't want war but it seems pretty
clear i refuse to accept that at this
point in time
david sir will you
correct your past mistake of exposing
folks to criminal liability through the
use of your coupon codes yes
i'm going to
try to correct that
absolutely absolutely the case
um yeah i can't really share links to
all this stuff right now because there's
just so so much going on
um
let's take a look at what's happening on
cnn
cnn appearing to be in some kind of
commercial break
uh okay a couple of other things while i
have you here
i do want to mention that this weekend
is cpac cpac in florida actually oh no
they're holding it in florida actually
and there's all sorts of wacky speakers
we are going to be live but look at who
is here this is tulsi gabbard democratic
presidential candidate who will be
speaking at cpac now i'm ready for all
of you guys
who fell for the tulsi thing to say we
were duped we were duped there was
nothing left-wing about tulsi as you can
see here they don't this is matt schlapp
announcing it tulsi gabbard 2020
presidential candidate and former
congresswoman really what party was she
from that would be very interesting to
know i wonder was she a republican or a
democrat i just don't remember and
tomorrow we're going to talk about the
whole toolsie thing but you know it's
there's all these people who
if if you hear someone say regime change
and endless wars you're like oh my
goodness this is my hero with with
applying no critical thinking whatsoever
um so yeah i mean it's it's absolutely
and completely pathetic what's going on
with tulsi but she will be at cpac we
will be live with cpac
live live live so it's going to be a
very busy week of streams it appears as
though
it appears as though
um the invasion of ukraine is starting
multiple reports including from bbc that
vladimir putin has ordered troops into
eastern ukraine if people have other
live feeds that we should be monitoring
please let me know
please let me know because we do want to
get to those but every indication that
that's the case we'll then have cpac
on monday i will deliver the state of
the show address on tuesday joe biden
next tuesday joe biden's delivering the
state of the union address so it is just
a crazy
week here
um of uh stuff to uh that that we will
be covering and again monitoring many
many feeds here let's listen to what fox
now is covering completely destroy that
even possibility
i i'm not quite sure who was advising
president biden on this but there's a
there's a little term which really
doesn't mean that much in english but it
means a lot in russian
um
and
what what president biden said was
we are agreeing to a summit in principle
and then he added if they don't obey
okay
all right when you in russia
uh
if you say in principle
it it has kind of the same meaning that
ensha law has in the middle east which
is god is if god wills it
it's another way to politely say
probably ain't gonna happen
got it
so when he said that it was diplomatic
speak but on the other hand
uh for russians and certainly for putin
he knows exactly what that means which
is
it's probably not going to happen and i
would say after this speech that he just
gave
it's almost assured that it's not going
to happen anytime soon
well we do know that he had a phone call
with uh zolensky okay yeah so let's
actually get to that let me see where
i've got
so many windows open okay there's a live
reddit thing
which is pretty pretty good and it's
just like there's a lot of it's sort of
a compilation of what's going on so
let's take a look at a little bit of
thing here in a conference call with
reporters on responding to putin and
what comes next the senior
administration officials suggested
russian troops in donetsk and luhansk
alone
may not warrant the swift and severe
sanctions the administration has been
previewing okay
um ukraine has requested an urgent
meeting of the u.n security council due
to russia's illegal actions we have
already sent the request to the council
russia's recognition of two separatist
territories is a violation of
international law
ukraine's territorial integrity and the
minsk agreement russia's propaganda
convinces no one australia continues to
work with partners to ensure severe
costs for russia's aggression
former ukrainian president yushenko was
poisoned with a lab-made toxin during
the 2004 election
rumors are being spread that all the top
ukrainian politicians and former leaders
including my husband have abandoned
ukraine this is not true
um
this stuff is happening constantly i
would like to okay here's the readout of
biden's call with
zelensky the president of ukraine
biden spoke with zelensky to reaffirm
the commitment of the u.s to ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
president biden strongly condemned
russian president putin's decision to
purportedly recognize the quote
independence of the dnr and l regions of
ukraine he updated president zielenski
on the state's response including our
plan to issue sanctions biden reiterated
that the us would respond swiftly and
decisively
in lockstep with its allies and partners
to further russian aggression against
ukraine and the question now is becoming
is this enough
is this enough
to warrant that swift response
that has been threatened and that so
many are talking about
um
and the answer is we don't know yet
we don't know yet
um
yeah we're gonna get back to cnn here in
a moment let me see what what's on
people's minds
denver says our only hope is to send
whitney as our star diplomat to broker
peace yeah whitney had a field day this
weekend
calling me all weekend here's just one
call she made
so i like recently started i stopped
striking
medical marijuana because i heard like
it might possibly kill you also
they're saying that like people
who might have like a small chance or a
larger chance of having multiple
personality disorder
um
that when
they smoke weed it's like
times five right
i believe that if we sent in whitney for
a summit with putin there would be no
war because putin would lose his mind
and just abandon everything and say i've
given up on life i can't i can't deal
with this i actually think it's a very
interesting idea
to look at uh
sending whitney in
um i do want to say thank you to
malfunction 99 oh wait a second we've
got news here
zolensky planning an announcement
oh yeah okay so there's major major
stuff happening here
let me see if i can get zelensky's
twitter
um
we've got breaking news here
twitter.comua
okay let's see
this is all happening in real time guys
i should really be following him okay so
most of this is not in english but here
it is
after the national security nsdc what's
nsdc
nsd anybody know what nsdc is
we don't know
anybody
is that the nationals is it national
national security defense council
okay
discuss the current situation with boris
now we are urgently preparing an address
and after that talks with euco president
charles michelle president of the
european council
uh and erdogan uh oh
pulling in erdogan now
yes zolensky will be giving a speech
tonight now bear in mind that in russia
it's 2 a.m right now maybe 1 a.m in
ukraine i don't know if ukraine is an
hour earlier than russia
so this imminently imminently we could
be seeing that and we're going to be
monitoring that closely
uh okay
let's call their bluff if it's a bluff
and then decide what to do next says
mart fillion all right well that's
that's one approach for sure
a thank you to malfunction 99 blueberry
babe for gifting and signing up can
feldus
as well as 90s nba fan critical heels
all of whom are supporting us via twitch
i appreciate that is a
rapidly evolving day here i also want to
say thank you on my website so many
people signing up with the new coupon
code please don't war
please don't war let's see if wolf
blitzer has news for us here it is into
separatist held areas of ukraine he
claims they're on a so-called
peacekeeping mission in regions he just
declared as independent the u.s and its
allies are scrambling to respond to
putin's provocation and fears that the
war they've been trying to prevent
may now become a reality cnn is on the
scene in russia in ukraine and here in
the u.s as we cover this major breaking
story let's see what's happening i want
to welcome our viewers here in the
united states and around the world i'm
wolf blitzer this is a situation room
special report
it is 2 am 3 2 a.m in russia but things
do not seem to be slowing down here
folks cnn breaking news let's get right
to the breaking news on vladimir putin
ordering so-called peacekeeping forces
into separatist held parts of ukraine
our chief international correspondent
clarissa ward is in the ukrainian
capital of key for us clarissa russian
troops could be arriving in ukraine very
very soon
well it is 1am in ukraine okay
that's right wolf and president
velodemir zielinski is expected to
address the nation sometime in the next
hour foreign minister dimitro kuleba has
also tweeted that he has requested an
immediate uh urgent u.n security i guess
they're staying up all night with this
issue as everyone tries to grapple with
how to respond with this fast breaking
story essentially what we know according
to this decree this sort of friendship
agreement between russia and the
independent or they would argue
independent republics of donetsk in lieu
ganks they have a 10-year
mutually-binding security decree which
allows and invites russia in to protect
borders to offer defense
and to offer also financial and economic
support
that could start to unfold any moment
now we could start to see russian troops
pouring across that border or trickling
across that border we simply don't know
exactly what to expect yet there have
already been a number of reports popping
up on social media none of which we have
been able to confirm but the real
concern here becomes wolf does this
constitute an invasion of course russia
will try to frame this within the
narrative that they have set out now
saying these are independent republics
requesting our help
but that is of course not going to be
the understanding of this by the
international community and certainly
not by the government here in kiev but
it remains to be seen how exactly they
will respond because obviously there's a
very real concern that if they respond
with force of any kind that could ignite
and escalate an even worse uh military
conflict wolf clarissa i want you to
stand by we'll be back to you in a
moment uh but right now i want to go to
the uh the white house our chief white
house correspondent caitlin collins is
getting new information for us caitlin
what are you picking up on as far as the
biden administration's response to putin
well we have seen president biden sign
this executive order imposing limited
economic sanctions on these two
territories that putin is describing is
independent now nothing on russia
directly or putin yet this is not
triggering the unleashing of that full
sanctions package that the white house
has been talking about for some time now
saying that that's what would happen and
that's what they would do in
coordination with allies if this
full-scale invasion were to occur and a
senior administration official who just
briefed reporters described that as
saying because russia has had forces in
this area since 2014 they don't consider
this to be a new step though of course
you are seeing the changes that have
been made today with the steps that
putin took which the white house has
described previously as would be in
violation of these international
agreements now they say there is more to
come they expect more sanctions activity
to happen tomorrow officials have not
detailed wolfe what exactly that would
look like or what those steps would be
though of course that is something that
everyone will be waiting to see what
exactly it is and when it comes to what
clarissa was just saying about these
report these reports of these troops
actually going in with the blessing of
putin the white house says they are
going to continue monitoring this over
the next several hours and looking at
what putin actually does not just what
he is saying though when it comes to
what he's saying they referenced that
speech that he gave today of course that
angry diatribe against ukraine saying
they've never been a true nation in and
of themselves they said that they
believed that was a speech to the
russian russian people to justify a war
and of course they have been warning
about the imminence of an attack here
with jake sullivan the national security
adviser saying this morning they could
believe they believed it could be
happening in hours or days and of course
that's a big question here of whether or
not they would use this
as a definition of an invasion it
doesn't appear that they are ready to
take that step though they say they will
be watching closely to see what it is
that putin does over the next several
hours and overnight wolf we shall see uh
caitlyn i want you to stay with us as
well clarissa ward is rejoining us from
ukraine also with us cnn contributor joe
dougherty she's in moscow and our
pentagon correspondent
lieberman oren the u.s expects russian
troops could move into the donbass
region of ukraine as soon as tonight or
tomorrow morning are we seeing the start
of what could be the biggest war in
europe potentially since world war ii
it's certainly possible and that is the
fear not only here in the pentagon but
throughout the u.s government and of
course many european officials with that
exact same fear i spoke with one
official who said this was the play they
expected from vladimir putin and it's
when they expected it now the question
is where does this go from here it's
clear that many believe this is the
justification he's using to create the
reasoning for an invasion it's worth
remembering you don't need 190 000
troops to declare that you've recognized
two parts of eastern ukraine as
independent you need that level of
troops if not only you're going to
destroy ukraine's military but also even
go beyond that for a full-scale invasion
it was defense secretary lloyd austin
who said over the weekend that the
possibility of russian tanks rolling
into kiev is highly likely and that's
not just an opinion of the defense
secretary that's the fear here that
putin will go all out here in his
attempt for regime change and control
over ukraine yeah it's an enormous fear
that's a growing and growing you know
jill you're there in moscow how do you
interpret these moves from putin the
dramatic announcement today just how
dangerous is this situation
i think it's dangerous because it's
incremental
and
uh you can kind of break it into little
pieces very carefully choreographed you
know let's go back a few days ago the
duma the lower house of parliament says
mr president please recognize these
regions president putin sits down with
his security council usually behind
doors this time in front of the cameras
they debate it they discuss it then he
makes the decision then he has a
dramatic speech and that the chilling
point to me was when he said any further
bloodshed will be on the conscience of
the ukrainian regime and then so listen
guys we're going to continue monitoring
and following this
we're banning all like somebody just
came in and said oh god women are giving
opinions you're just banned for life
guys it's just we're not gonna tolerate
even an iota of it it's it's just toxic
go go you know go find some other
channel i'm sure that they would welcome
you
uh on on a whole bunch of other channels
where that counts as funny don't even
bother requesting an unban okay just
don't even don't even waste your time uh
if you're just joining us the big big
news today is that in a sort of two
part move
first vladimir putin recognized two
regions that contain separatists in
ukraine two regions those regions are
donetsk and luhansk i know my
pronunciations are a disaster these two
regions right here
then on the basis that those are now
legitimate separatists putin is ordering
troops into those regions in order to
keep them safe they're calling them
peacekeeping regions and that is what is
being discussed here on cnn
and this could very quickly escalate we
are also expecting to hear
from the ukrainian president mind you
it's one in the morning in ukraine
it's two in the morning in moscow what
are russia's time is
all of russia's not on on one time zone
is it uh russian time zones that would
be that would be insane no it's not
russia looks like it has one two three
four five six seven eight nine time
zones okay so it's 2 a.m
in uh in moscow it's already tomorrow
morning
out
out to the east i believe it's china
that has everything in one time zone
isn't it china time zones
uh no even china now has a few time
zones okay in any case
it is it's 2 a.m in moscow not 2 a.m in
russia generally speaking uh but this is
uh this is what is going on right now
before i fall further behind i know many
of you are appreciative of the coverage
and are sending your thanks i want to
say thank you to hell muffin hippie
chick and brotherhood of steel for the
twitch subscriptions also over on our
website and i apologize i haven't
thanked anybody here we go
justin bennett just signed up with our
coupon code please don't war
beans bag of donuts has signed up on my
website richard diaz tamargo is a new
member
ryan meckin has signed up
joshua bullard and tim haskins our new
members and also thank you to jason howe
who has also signed up the the coupon
code is please don't war we don't want a
war we are not
imperialists or whatever it is alex
jones says globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike obama trudeau mccrown and the
rest of these zio beasts
pac-man's a loser exactly none of that
stuff is going on here we're just
monitoring what is taking place
it looks like the u.n has broken for the
time being
we have been casually monitoring what's
going on with stunk futures and they are
down
we have a very very good
apology from hassan [ __ ] who says his
take earlier was completely wrong it's
great to see that and hassan coming
around on that and as you can see i
jumped right in and congratulated him on
coming around to the correct take glenn
greenwald is going uh glenn grift
greenwald i think ggg
is the right nickname there we already
talked about that and then we are
monitoring a number of different feeds
let's listen here a joint session of the
foreign affairs council with ukrainian
partners in kiev
i want to confirm that our embassies and
diplomatic missions remain open
and fully operational
with the single exception of one country
all others
remain
at give
their emphasis are there open and
operational 26
plus the european union delegation
it will be soon eight years
since russia invaded and illegally and
exit crimea
and i want to repeat when again that any
further aggressions against ukraine will
have
a strong answer from the european union
but i want to add
that this will also apply to belarus
should an attack be conducted from its
territory
of with its involvement
belarus is being dragged into the crisis
he's losing his health
guys am i crazy for being against
invasions
and annexations like am i is it crazy
that that's my position
nuclear neutrality
in a process of satisfaction
with respect to russia
now it's up to russia
to the russian leadership
to decide
how they want to be sent
by the international community
and by history
on bosnia segovina
we discuss about how to preserved
disoberented in territorial integrity
and the unity of the country
we have urged political leaders to take
responsibility to preserve the
constitution ensure
full return to state institutions
and it will open issues
there is no place in europe for a
divided borders
and those who work in this direction are
strongly wrong they are depriving their
people
of a prosperous european perspective on
life
the ministers express their full support
to the european union spell
representative
the european union force altea
and to the high representative smith
and to the efforts of facilitation
that we are deploying from the external
action service
under my direction okay we have more
breaking news here following what is
going on reuters can now report that
ukrainian soldiers are reporting
frontline shelling frontline shelling
oh man this is this is just this is not
the best this is um
okay reuters
ukrainian soldiers report intensified
frontline shelling and fear provocations
government troops in front-line trenches
in ukraine's east said on monday heavy
weapons fired from russian-backed
separatists had intensified to provoke
all-out conflict so
imagine
the separatists escalate
putin recognizes the separatists and
then says we've got to go in and keep
the peace because the separatists are
now involved in scuffles and kerfuffles
ukrainian troops have battled
russian-backed forces in donetsk and
luhansk regions bordering russia since
2014.
estimate is 15 000 people have been
killed
ceasefire in 2015 staunch the worst
fighting but shelling has intensified
along the line of contact since last
week
western governments have accused the
kremlin of preparing to fabricate a
pretext for a military offensive into
ukraine by blaming kiev for attacks and
relying on pleas for help from
separatist proxies
the last few days it has become very hot
here
they shoot at us everywhere along the
front with heavy mortars it has become
much more dangerous it's probably to
provoke us so that we answer their fire
and they might
i'm guessing here want to provoke us
into a full-blown war
russia denies any such plan
but has threatened unspecified military
technical action elements of technical
unless it receives sweeping security
guarantees and a promise that ukraine
will never join nato seems like the ship
has sailed on that
uh okay
oh man
u.s is moving its ukraine embassy staff
out of the country and into poland they
may return tomorrow if there's no
invasion
interfax news the equivalent of ap in
russia reports two columns of armored
vehicles inside the dpr guys there's
every indication that they're moving in
and that they're moving in very strongly
christopher miller christopher jm on
twitter okay let me get to that in a
moment we're all trying to synthesize
the information that's coming in
we'll get to christopher miller in a
moment
google translate
a large number of armored vehicles were
seen on the territory of the do they say
donetsk people's republic as
eyewitnesses told interfax two columns
of armored vehicles are on the territory
of the dpr and follow to the north and
west
breaking us cannot commit to a summit
with putin when it looks like moscow
will take
military action
yeah
yeah
so we're going to continue monitoring
all of that
because things are certainly moving
quickly oh let's take a look at what
christopher
miller is saying on twitter i'm being
pointed in that direction
christopher miller correspondent for
buzzfeed news i'm going to follow
christopher
uh let's see what the latest is
putin has officially ordered troops into
eastern ukraine using false and unproven
reports as justification putin ordered
russian troops in calling it a
peacekeeping mission okay we've we've
got that
seems like there's not too much
additional
the interfax translated thing on a
number of armored vehicles yet there's
every indication that they're moving in
it it's just what it seems like right
now
let's listen
this is not a peacekeeping operation and
we need to stop uh enabling putin with
even the use of that word these are
units of the russian military who are
i'm calling it a quote peacekeeping
operation is that clear enough sovereign
territory of ukraine to further that
occupation and to expand it right now
russia's
surrogates and russian troops occupy
about a third of donetsk and luhansk
what he proposes to do immediately is to
extend that to the remaining two thirds
that is an invasion by any sense of the
imagination
well what do you think the u.s should do
about that uh if the if if you regard
that let's see how warmongering this guy
is invasion what should the u.s do
there are three immediate things we
should do
we should impose
some of the most
consequential sanctions ever
contemplated by an alliance like ours uh
that will [ __ ] the russian economy
okay in in virtually every critical
sector uh making it almost impossible
for russia to function in the modern
economy certainly through the financial
sector and through trade investment and
exports and imports
secondly uh we need to shore up our nato
borders to make it very clear to putin
that we are prepared uh to protect nato
members from any encouragement remember
ukraine not a nato member and thirdly we
need to help the ukrainians defend
themselves and that means providing
military equipment training uh and
and the like to help them defend their
own territory against the russians
remember there are 41 million ukrainians
uh and they have yet to be heard from
with this so remember that joe biden has
said u.s troops will not go to ukraine
but there's been every expectation
indeed that there would be more military
aid provided and that seems to be
exactly what this democratic congressman
is calling for from sent from russia
into eastern ukraine would constitute a
further invasion of the country is that
a mistake should the white house be
blunt and say yes this is an invasion
i think
wolf i think the white house gets a lot
of credit so far and how it's managed
the situation in calling out
uh the disinformation in advance
uh of vladimir putin yeah so i mean i i
think it's completely legitimate to say
that
if we you know if if you so so listen uh
man
this is a very complicated situation and
it would be very difficult to just kind
of like swing on by for two minutes and
for me to be always be able to squeeze
everything i think into those two
minutes so inevitably things are going
to be missing but i think on the one
hand
it is unquestionable to me that russia
is the aggressor here
the argument that
well toying with ukraine maybe being
part of nato not ruling it out is
aggression well
you you can say it feels like aggression
but it's not aggression in the way that
an invasion is aggression
number one
uh okay oh no okay
number two
um while
that is my belief
i am not
ignorant or naive to the fact that if
the position of the u.s is okay we're
not sending troops but
we're sanctioning russia economically in
a brutal way which i'm not saying i
disagree with
we are
shoring up the defense of nato
which doesn't include ukraine but it
includes nearby countries and we're
sending russia weapon ukraine russia
ukraine weapons and training
it's basically a proxy war right i mean
like do do
do people disagree with that assessment
in the chat let me know like all of
those things together short of sending
troops
it's more or less a proxy war yes one
that we're in a sense committing to by
saying we'll do what nato you know we're
part of nato and all of nato maybe maybe
doing like we're basically saying it's a
proxy war right
most people seem to be agreeing with me
okay
yeah
i'm not saying
putin's good right actually while we
have a break
should i take this opportunity to just
remind you guys about something a new
thing that i'm going to be trying to do
i'm i'm going to try i this is a clip i
recorded today where i explain i'm no
longer going to explain myself to idiots
i'll just play this for you guys this
isn't publishing for a while but i
recorded it today just to give you guys
a sense of my new approach on stuff like
this okay listen to this i want to make
a goal of mine publicly known so that
you can hold me to it you know one of
the best ways to actually get something
done is to tell other people that you
plan to do it and my goal is to stop
explaining myself to idiots now you
might say whoa whoa sir that's very
aggressive language what do you mean in
order to try to save myself from
thousands of horrible comments tweets
and emails i will often over explain
things and give disclaimers and i really
am only doing that
to people who are just nuts or are bad
faith actors so like when i say hey guys
you know in the in the russia ukraine
thing putin's the aggressor but to be
clear i don't support american
imperialism i don't think the u.s is a
perfect actor with an unblemished record
to foreign uh foreign relations i do not
favor the u.s sending troops to ukraine
i do not think the u.s should choose the
leaders in other countries and all of
those disclaimers are really for like
five percent of my audience now i wish
it was like one percent or less but it
is about five percent of the audience
but it's a very loud five percent it's a
very weaponized five percent but most of
you know that i don't mean invade russia
when i say putin is being the aggressor
here and likewise when i say you know
i can't support the former chavez now
maduro regime in venezuela because
they've raped and pillaged the country's
resources for themselves while spewing
false populist rhetoric about how
they're going to help everybody
meanwhile people can't even afford food
which there are shortages of anyway i
don't mean invade venezuela i don't mean
assassinate maduro i don't mean that the
u.s should pick who is the leader in
venezuela i only mean i don't like
maduro 95 of you get that but the five
percent that don't or refuse to are
really loud and really annoying but this
isn't normal this isn't a normal way to
talk about things and this is sadly a
toxic reality of the internet this is
kind of like how twitter works and
social media all these platforms select
and and highlight
reactionaries and outrageous responses
to content right give you kind of like a
benign example i post a picture of
myself having a cappuccino at a coffee
shop in los angeles the way i did two
months ago this was on instagram not
twitter 99 of the people who see me with
my stupid cappuccino say nothing i never
hear from 99 of the people who see that
picture one percent leave a comment
90 of the comments are completely normal
weather looks great looks great have fun
yeah okay of the comments okay so we're
talking ten percent of the one percent
the people who choose to comment of
those comments ten percent people go
crazy david you're traveling during a
pandemic you're so irresponsible how
dare you you know people died of kova
today
the other one you're not wearing a mask
david si you don't you don't care about
other people you're so self-centered
that you drink a cappuccino with no mask
and number three are you drinking cow's
milk how are you not a vegan you're a
terrible person um it's not normal and
social media really skews this because
most people see a guy with a coffee and
they move on with their day but the
internet has created this almost
defensive status quo for posting
anything and on my show i'm in this
defensive mode whenever i comment on
stuff even though anybody normal or
acting in good faith realizes these are
not normal reactions and that i'm not
saying
whatever the worst faith possible
interpretation of my words actually
right so my new effort is going to be
not to do the disclaimers and the
defensiveness when i just give my
opinion about things on the show because
at the end of the day not only is it
preposterous to cater to people who are
quite frankly nuts or bad faith actors
it also won't stop them from saying the
exact same things i've got an example
for you look at the comments on my
recent russia clips in those videos i
say putin is the aggressor but i'm not
an imperialist i don't want war
i don't want u.s troops there i don't
want u.s involvement beyond you know if
nato as an organization says well we're
going to support ukraine in some way i
don't want the u.s doing regime change
and i look at the video and i see
comments like the ones i'm i'm putting
up on the screen for you right now
you're just repeating establishment
talking points and neocon lies david i'm
not imperialist but let's have war
now i i did the disclaimers and i still
got the comment next comment you are an
imperialist
no no no i explained it another comment
tulsi is a twisted grifter but you're
brazenly lying warmongering imperialist
trash david
i'm gonna do my best because either way
they're gonna say that stuff right
right so that's the new thing okay where
was i i don't even know why why why did
i even play that i don't even know no
i'm kidding uh oh hey john cypher john
cypher follows me on uh on twitter let's
listen to what he has to say the demise
of the soviet union was the greatest
geopolitician
of the century and there was one soviet
republic he especially regretted losing
okay so we're not live what we are
standing in all seriousness guys we are
standing by for the president of ukraine
it's now 1 27 a.m in kiev and 2 27 a.m
in moscow and we are told the ukrainian
president will soon be speaking we'll
soon be speaking um
huge thank you to manny the be dizzle
andre bavaria
i really appreciate you guys and your
twitch prime subscriptions i really do
over on my website i want to say thank
you to aaron rutherford
and kirsten bowle
who just signed up at joinpakman.com we
have a we have the obama coupon code
we also have a new code it's unpublished
heretofore unpublished and the code is
please don't war because we don't want a
war okay
uh super chats okay i already read this
one i guess we have no other super chats
right now right
sir oh okay
ryan sir would you be open to a
discussion or debate with kyle kelinski
he did with vaush on this topic i don't
know what
would you be open to a discussion debate
with kyle kolinsky he did with vaush am
i open to watching the debate no i
i i don't care guys i i don't know i
don't know anything about it i don't
even know what kyle thinks about this i
don't watch any shows like mine
um i don't even know
what what i don't even know what we
would debate to be totally honest like
i'm not sure
um
yeah
we're we're pretty busy over here with
uh with with our thing
okay
let's see um
what else is going on
we do have uh
do we have live video let me see here
okay here's boris so i would i would
encourage people they will they will
they will lose out and i would encourage
people to uh to to get back to work with
confidence i think you know we have we
have the right now we have okay this
seems mostly to be about covid which is
okay
uh we have video in keeve
we have other video
in kiev
and i mean it is almost the middle of
the night so things seem relatively calm
there uh but we are we are monitoring
everything that's going on let's hear
from james clapper not that i find him
particularly trustworthy but let's let's
listen with the two so-called people's
republics in the donbass region
uh and what worries me is uh
what happens after uh ukraine uh and i
think you know we've got a real uh real
crisis on our hands here what do you
mean when you say what happens after
ukraine you think he's ambitious enough
to go after
other countries in eastern europe
including nato allies
well i i wonder uh you know i i wouldn't
uh i wouldn't bet my paycheck that he
wouldn't do that uh i mean i you know
he's not getting a lot of advice from
people that are uh telling that uh some
of his ideas are bad
uh he's surrounded by
uh sycophants that are yes men
so he's not getting opposing uh opinions
or opposing views it's just hard to
imagine like okay you know so
you're telling me putin has people
around him where when putin goes hey
listen
uh
europe gets like 30 of their energy from
us so we got them over a barrel
no one goes right but that 30 percent of
their energy is 80 of our revenue
that's bad
nope does nobody think to say that like
literally the sycophants around him are
that sycophantic attacking all 30 nato
countries they are all committed to
responding
that's that's correct and uh i
this may not take the form of an overt
invasion
uh there are other as we've seen uh
there are other forms of attack
that uh putin could use not only in the
cyber realm so i
i think uh and and yeah maybe putin
doesn't have any any any dudes around
him as some are suggesting and we will
ban men diva says if we could go back to
pre-world war ii for a do-over would we
not stop hitler from invading poland
would we not stop
would we not stop
i don't i don't even know what i'm not
sure i'm not sure i understand foley
diva what you mean
steinar from norway says do you think
this is the beginning of a cold war
between liberal democracy and
authoritarianism i'm worried the u.s is
going to have a hard time picking aside
this time yeah by tomorrow i expect 40
percent of twitter to be supportive of
putin's
aggression for sure
bae photo have to wonder if a small
reason for putin's invasion of ukraine
is because trump didn't fully dismantle
nato
i don't know about that
alex says are we going to start calling
moscow mules freedom mules after this
seems like the natural reaction to this
situation oh boy
that's uh that's above my pay grade to
be to be perfectly frank
let's see the latest here very very
interesting live thread on reddit world
news michelle nichols says us britain
france ask for u.n security council
meeting on monday evening
it is up to russia as council president
to schedule it u.n security council to
meet publicly at 9 00 pm eastern russian
diplomat speaking on the condition of
anonymity a lot is going to happen here
a lot is going to happen here uh oh
oh man i gotta start we're we're just
blocking
oh my god what is happening on twitch
is completely insane
it's just dozens of people having to get
banned okay okay okay we already looked
at that fine
so we're continuing continuing to
monitor all of these uh
all of these different feeds
um
thank you thank you very much appreciate
that
all right let's see do we want to do i i
have so many different things that i was
going so we talked about cpac we'll be
live with cpac let's just close out some
things
so cpac is going to be insane tulsi the
last real liberal will be speaking at
cpac
um
we're monitoring
zelensky's twitter
christopher miller with a number of
different relevant tweets
um
here we go
let's just get through a couple other
things i had
oh yeah this is this is good so um
walter masterson who does these
fantastic videos he was recently at the
ottawa truck convoy i'm just going to
show you guys this week walter turns out
he's a fan of the show he's reached out
we're going to have them on soon okay
this is really really good stuff the
socialist agenda we need to get rid of
these big pharma companies yeah like
pfizer and moderna pfizer moderna that's
right you know what amazon we need to
get rid of amazon if we want to stop
taxes are enough and we don't revolt we
eat poutine we drink maple syrup you
guys need to fight for your freedom
because there is an underlying agenda
that's going on i don't know how much
you know i'm not going to get into that
the workers need to unite against uh
socialism the workers of the world need
to unite and seize the means of
production and everything thank you
what do you think are some things we can
do to fight the socialist agenda love
truth we have to hold a line put our
foot on the ground and say enough is
enough the real
root cause of the socialist agenda is
the banks yeah the big banks yeah yeah
yeah the big banks through big pharma
big tech uh media big media i'm out of
here because we're done we lose this
fight this country's over canada has
always been a socialist type of country
you've been living under socialism for a
long time because of the healthcare well
yeah because of the healthcare and they
you know they sneak it in here they
stick it in there everybody gets used to
it now everybody woke up like heavily
heavily woke up what's the socialism
like it's like you want to see a doctor
and then you see a doctor and then like
they don't charge you
if you had a car accident
emergency is fast
because it's a socialist health care
system they're using they call like a
triage thing sort of yeah
it's what we have in there it's like you
know you want to pay to see the doctor
you pay to see the doctor so like i can
pay to see the doctor right away yeah
and it's like i know i don't have to
wait and do this like socialist triage
system like in they have in canada you
think these insurance companies are part
of the socialist agenda oh for sure
that's always the same clicks making the
money
you can have cars doing 50 miles at a
gallon a long time ago trust me a long
long time the automotive automotive
industry is definitely part of the
socialist agenda oh yeah for sure i mean
they're all in bed together it's all
who pays the bill right us
the consumer the tax the taxpayer the
middle class we always get the bill
right
so that's walter masterson doing a
really really good job and we're going
to get um he's going to be on the show
soon we did this we did that
oh here's just here's a full grow let me
let me just we're monitoring okay cnn's
in a break okay
this is a full-grown man full-grown man
okay
throwing a tantrum and having to be
carried around because he just won't put
a mask on to go on the ski lift this is
an adult guys technically
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a literal tantrum exactly
imagine having to be carried around like
this as an adult
[Music]
what a humiliation
[Music]
yeah it is like a kid refusing to nap
all right
anyway i won't even play the whole thing
because we have so much else going on
that's that's just completely
humiliating uh oh we did this thing
already okay good i do think we're more
or less uh caught up here um as we
continue to monitor
the situation
in a number of different places and if
anybody has any specific streams that we
should be looking at by all means let me
know and we will do that but the latest
news if you were just joining us putin
has recognized two regions that have
separatists in them in ukraine and then
subsequently has said hey since we
recognize them we've got to make sure
that we're keeping the peace there so
we've got to send troops in as well
that is the latest
and there are reports there are reports
that there are already columns of
vehicles
that are
on their way in that was reported at
uh what time was that reported at 37
minutes ago and expecting imminently
imminently a speech from the ukrainian
president it is 1 39 in the morning in
ukraine
and 2 39 in the morning in moscow
and extraordinarily frustrating
situation
sinsu says 21 was supposed to be better
than 20 22 was supposed to be better
than 21 god help us in 2023 if we get
there
uh understandable feeling
understandable feeling
thank you to sterling lana for gifting
two subs drewbs and sir charles of
bradley
very much appreciate that
um and we are all waiting we are all
waiting to see
what will happen
if and when so the the time the
important time elements right now are
any moment
the ukrainian president zielenski is
expected to speak
and then at 9 00 pm eastern time the un
security council will be meeting that's
going to be 5 a.m in moscow that's going
to be 4 a.m in kiev but apparently
everybody's staying up all night
because of what's going on
jmintyfresh asks via super chat hi david
how are you do you think we're headed
towards world war iii if so do you think
attacks on u.s soil by russia are
imminent no
attacks on u.s soil by russia are not
imminent but we may be heading to the
largest war in europe since world war ii
it's just it it's just what we could be
heading towards i'm not predicting it
and i'm not saying that i want it i'm
just saying that's what we could be
what we could be heading towards
um
a lot of people asking about the timing
of the olympics ending before putin did
this
i i can't make anything out of that
definitively
um
i i just don't i just don't you know i
have nothing specific to say about it
um
but yeah maybe there's something to it
i don't know
curious curious what some of you guys
think
um a couple of other yeah let's do a
couple of other voicemails here
let's see
david pickman
why do you keep proper guy
propagandizing about tariffs in
and slanting for china
uh and you play the caller not only do
you repeat this lie but then you play a
caller who agrees with you you're
ignoring economics
we don't need to be buying chinese stuff
that that because what's the whole point
of trump's tariffs is to encourage more
domestic production right the thing is
it would take years to bring those
supply lines those supply processes to
the u.s
at insane cost
and people are complaining about
inflation now
do you know what would happen
i mean we can do that it's just a lot of
these people who are like no no trump's
tariffs will just bring everything will
be produced domestically
our economy has been based implicitly
and explicitly to some degree
on the premise
of get we prefer cheap stuff from china
rather than paying more in making it
here it's a decision that's been made
now you didn't make it no one person
made it but when we when you look at the
totality of trade agreements
employment law
tax all these different things
over decades as a country we've decided
we value having stuff be cheaper
and giving jobs to people in other
countries to make that stuff over
manufacturing it here and paying more
that's the decision that's been made
cumulatively over time so to say well
just tariff everything and make it all
here sure
take 10 20 years to reorganize the
economy in the meantime causing more
shortages and more inflation you can do
it
but to pretend you just tariff china
then suddenly bing bang boom you make
everything here it's all fine it doesn't
cost anymore come on guys give me a
break it started in the 80s that's
exactly right
that's exactly right
guys
bring that to somebody else you know
it's come on
come on
um okay as we stand by here a couple
other voicemails
hey david it's sarah from math i just
watched your conspiratorial video
great video i think i've taken it out
i think you guys are too trusting and
think that whatever anyone tells you on
tv is true no i mean listen trump would
go on tv and lie all the time we didn't
fall for it fox news lies all the time
we don't fall for it no eric from mass
continues to deliver these
completely delusional screeds
that make
no sense to anybody other than himself
but it's like so ridiculous how some of
these people merge around
and like have you seen some of their
vessels they're like heinously ugly and
they have no money and they have like no
privilege or power or anything in the
world or anything to offer whatsoever
and they're saying like jews will not
replace us god we gotta send whitney in
to negotiate peace between russia and
ukraine i think we'd have it wrapped up
in immediately
ron says on the off chance of a russia
u.s war russia can hit the u.s mainland
with conventional weapons yeah my
prediction is russia's not going to
attack the u.s mainland okay i i just i
don't know how much i should entertain
something
that right now
i just don't believe is uh going to
happen i just i just
i just don't think it's going to happen
um
let's see here hi oh uh i was trying to
call the david pakman
show with joe walsh
uh i don't know if you're taking phone
calls
um what i want to say is
um the two of you have ignored
the real authentic uh dictator yes troy
atatorian i know i know we're ignoring
everything it's just it's it's quite
quite unremarkable here's my question
for this [ __ ] in his make-believe
church
talking about people he wants to expel
calling them witches
i want to know where
are the fbi
undercover
and informants working on this guy to
assassinate him
this guy's worthy of assassination these
kind of people are worthy of
assassination okay we that's not a i i
don't endorse assassinating anybody
oof wow i don't even know that we can
stay on the voicemails
so backpack do you ever wonder about
like if fossils and bones were missing
like maybe our ancestors like
threw away
bones and fossils
and stuff like that like i was wondering
if there was like a way
in which
our ancestors could have like
destroyed a bunch of evidence
about like evolution
if there's anything that like destroys
bones
and fossils
like stone
like is there like some tar
that like i really could drain like a
ginormous hole of char that you could
just like throw stuff in or things like
could have possibly gotten lost
because guys i think i'm having a stroke
oh my god what what is happening
i don't think i can do it
i just don't think i can do it
it's uh
man
i don't know
hey david you're missing out actually
you're doing a really good job
listen uh
world is one news uh they have live
feeds
in ukraine so just want to let you know
brother
okay
let me check that out see that's an
update i can use
in the sahara
let's see what we've got going that's
that's an actionable in 2012 and since
then the country
oh there's one news is this it
the world is one news
they seem to be covering something
different right now
uh but we will
we will monitor it and standing by for
uh zelensky's speech
um okay
david reports of weak sanctions from the
u.s directed only at dpr lpr when can we
expect heavier sanctions on russia
itself i don't know yeah that's a lot of
people are asking that exact question
although people are catastrophizing i
don't see russia extending much past
ukraine well no no not past ukraine
taking i mean going further into ukraine
would be bad enough
i agree
david world war three isn't important
did you see the new
euphoria episode last night i don't know
what that is
what's you i don't know what euphoria is
i do want to say thank you to titan mars
productions for the twitch prime sub
also thanks to toil and kismar who has
gifted five that's a total of seven
putting us at 37.
if you are just joining us please make
sure you're signed up at joinpackman.com
oh that's one other thing i wanted to
say guys so oh where'd it go i lost it
you know we're all going to have a grand
old time laughing at cpac this week
we're going to be streaming starting on
thursday it's going to be a [ __ ] show
it's going to be cartoonish it's going
to be you know a gong show we're all
gonna laugh at cpac but
but
i wish the left was as organized as the
right such that we could put together
something like cpac i mean
the right understands you've got to fund
this stuff that's why the right funds
cpac
they fund
turning point they fund uh daily wire
they understand all this stuff the left
doesn't do it and that's why as as
cartoon cpac's going to be a mess but
they're all going to go and feel great
about it and be energized we have what
le net roots nation which is like
it's a huge part of net roots nation is
is like the worst of the left you know
it's not even it it's it's it's bad
so um
support something it doesn't have to be
this show i'd love it if you signed up
at joinpacman.com we have this coupon
code obama
sign up for something right let's get
something going here
man
it is something else
just you playing whitney and sitting
through it is comedy genius thanks
tristan
i appreciate that
i do appreciate that i you know should
we allow cyrillic in the chat i think we
shouldn't moderators we should make a
decision i think we can't allow it
because
really i think english and spanish is
what's allowed here
um i know we're covering russia and
ukraine but i don't really think we can
do it we just don't know what people are
saying and
anything could be said we i don't think
we can do it
so i think moderators
you can't allow it if you can't moderate
it that's exactly right exactly right
um
yeah that is a freaking predator right
there and by the way if you're wondering
about the bonus show
alex jones hates the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah
okay
so that that's that as far as uh as far
as i am concerned let's see if we have
any updates as to the scheduling
uh oh here we go
potus
has signed an executive order
imposing costs because of what putin did
let's see
fact sheet
executive order to impose costs for
putin's action to recognize so-called
donetsk and luhansk province people's
republics
what did he actually do
the following is banned new investment
in the dnr or lnr
okay but hold on a second
we
don't we need to punish russia
in its like russia proper
i'm not sure about this
does this does this make sense to attack
the dnr
and the lnr with sanctions shouldn't we
be attacking the person doing it
like are we allowing this by
i'm going to have to look at this in
more detail but it's seeming a little
bit suspect
all of these things are going right
after those regions
the purpose is to deny russia the chance
to profit
oh i don't know about this guys i'm not
sure
yeah i don't i don't know it seems yeah
it seems like france is sort of
outflanking biden on this we're going to
have to look at that very closely before
tomorrow's show
um
u.s officials discussed the ukrainian
president leaving the capital
and relocating to western ukraine
okay the fact that that's a discussion
means it's probably
very very real
and the un security council will be
meeting tonight
we'll be meeting tonight so that's going
on
um
[Music]
christopher says western sanctions on
russia will not hurt the russians as the
chinese will offset them
okay
david do you believe trump's campaign to
delegitimize nato and deterior
deteriorate u.s standing across the
globe is why putin is deciding to move
now no i don't think so
un security council meeting is 9 p east
9 p east tonight
9 p east tonight okay and actually on
that note
i think i'm gonna pause now because it
seems like i'm getting a report that it
will be at least a little bit until
zelensky speaks and the u.n security
council is not meeting until nine
so i think what i'm i just may come back
and do a second stream tonight
uh it seems that we're at a bit of a uh
a bit of a pause here
uh so let's do that we have i think
learned everything we're going to learn
in the immediate at this point in time
keeve is calm
but we are going to be hearing from the
ukrainian president and the u.n security
council will meet that'll be close to
morning time in ukraine and russia so i
will bid you adieu for the time being uh
gonna go make a tuna melt some of you
saw my tweet last night about tuna melt
i am now ready to make the tuna melt
and we will monitor and see you all
later today
thank you